the FBI here's a piece of gossip door
informations
prefer not the woman on his wife we're
supposed to write everything down in
memos all your secrets are safe with us
how long have you been in the FBI
30 years that's a lot of information I
give you the guardian of the American
dream mark felt fidelity tegrity bravery
ladies and gentlemen the g-man's g-man
what is it a good time here five men
were caught early this morning in the
Washington headquarters of the
Democratic National Committee here's
what we know the men who broke into the
Watergate are not the end of this think
of the beginning you know more
interviews with White House people
without permission once we put the
investigation to bed in two days the
director of the FBI ordered the FBI to
stop its own investigation tonight is in
the midst would be the most critical
constitutional crisis in its history the
White House has no authority over the
FBI we can at all all this truth
you must be terrified to you no one can
stop the driving force of an FBI
investigation
not even the FBI what you're doing will
bring down the whole house of cards this
comes from classified FBI files the
White House has it and now you have it
FBI agents have established Watergate
incident as political sabotage there's a
spy in the FBI the White House is gonna
sanitize the entire town how high how
high does this go what about the
president is the president lying they're
all lying
there's a nickname for you at the paper
deep throat
you